so for our latest movie review we are
reviewing a horror classic phantasm yes
the low-budget cult classic that started
a franchise I saw the trailer for this
when it came out I must have been about
nine it scared the [ __ ] out of me that
trailer bothered me there was something
kind of subversive about this movie and
I remember some of the kids I went to
school with saw it they'd come back and
reported to me what the movie was about
and it always had this dark mystique
because I would never really saw it and
they weren't planted on HBO later when
cable started yeah it was almost kind of
like in your mind or my mind
HBO wasn't allowed phantasm that's how
it kind of saw it but really seeing it
now and I got the blu-ray edition the
blu-ray edition fantastic I recommend
yeah they totally remastered it looks
really good for what it was but seeing
it now I realize well it wasn't on HBO
because it was basically kind of like a
homemade low-budget disposable it was
very low-budget in a very low budget the
movie was a low budget but it was
effective yeah alright it was it was fun
to watch and you know what unique yeah
it wasn't ripping off anything else that
I could tell in terms of you know like
weird stuff like orange blood and killer
Jawas and yeah a round ball with a bunch
of spikes on it that would bore into
your head chute blown out of the back
you know like it's like a human juicer
is pretty cool get out hmm
human smoothie it would the movie was
trying to create its own mythos its own
more in its own world and I liked that
and yeah I could tell that this was made
by people that cared they love the
detail yeah that they were telling yeah
well I should say I mean my experience
with the phantasm series I actually saw
phantasm - first I saw it in the theater
that came out in 1988 and I had heard
about phantasm I knew the tall man was
and stuff like that and I really really
liked the second one so then I went back
and rented the first one now I ended up
liking the second one better just
because it's more accomplished and I
hadn't seen the first one in a long time
until you got the blu-ray and we watched
it I'd heard a tall man I didn't realize
that this is where that came from
yeah I didn't know that was a tall man
yeah I've seen
guy you know over the years here and
there I've never seen this movie I've
seen maybe little snippets of it but
have you seen it now I'm glad i watch
some of the little snippets I remembered
yeah like the other didn't going into
the other dimension at the end yeah and
I was like okay this that's where that
came from yeah I think the coolest thing
about this movie and you know if you
don't know obviously this is a classic
but if you don't know the movie came out
in 1979 written directed edited
photographed pretty much everything by
Don Coscarelli this was a very
amateurish effort I guess I mean it was
basically him and all his friends they
filmed it over the course of a year just
whenever they could get people to be
free yeah they pretty much did all the
[ __ ] themselves I did Don Kaas Carly's
mom did like some of the special effects
and yeah up and tell that mausoleum was
a cheap set with a bunch of wallpaper on
it right right but I I appreciated the
effort yeah yeah the charm of the booth
I think is coolest thing about the first
phantasm is the concept behind it yeah I
mean this is one of the weirdest
premises you know of any of the movies
from the pier is very original I liked
it it's very original now it should be
noted and the Wikipedia page goes a
little bit into this Don Coscarelli I
don't think he had made a horror movie
prior to this but he was very into her
from childhood and so he thought well
I'm gonna make a horror movie because
his movies before that hadn't really
done very well in horror movies were
actually doing pretty good Halloween had
come out the previous year and stuff so
he decided he was gonna try as hand at
doing one now originally what he wanted
to do was he wanted to make an
adaptation of Something Wicked This Way
Comes by Ray Bradbury now obviously that
the rights to that had been sold to
someone else because it was made into a
movie by someone else so he decided to
write his own original story now he
liked the idea of Suspiria where it was
kind of like nightmarish and all this
weird [ __ ] happened and they didn't
really explain anything he liked that he
also liked the soundtrack of Suspiria so
the soundtrack of the first phantasm is
very goblin esque or you know very prog
rock kind of sounding like I said the
coolest thing about this
movie is that and I think you said this
last night you said the movie really
punches above its weight yeah it has
this really rich mythos but in the first
movie they really didn't they couldn't
explore it to a huge extent because they
didn't have the budget but the ideas
behind it were so intriguing it you
wanted to know more that you wanted to
know more about it so this is almost
something that needed sequels because it
needed to expand its universe when he
had more money to kind of yeah after you
left that out after you get done seeing
it you're like wait a minute hold on was
that another dimension or was a hell but
you know yeah was another planet what
was going away you know were they really
shrinking them down because of the
gravity yeah just ridiculous [ __ ] but I
liked it yeah I couldn't I could
understand it's kind of like kind of in
like kind of like in the way that Evil
Dead needed sequels yeah like I said
because they didn't have the money to
expand upon this original idea they had
right so you know once you get more
money you can kind of open that up a
little bit and explain it a little bit
more although in a way it was kind of
cooler that it wasn't explained there
was just like here's this more chew Airy
yeah you're intrigued you're like what
the [ __ ] was that hey here's this
mortuary in this town and there's a
mortician in there the tall man is
that's all he's ever called and he's
super creepy he has yellow alien blood
he's strong he's super strong he has all
these little bitty like dwarves with
little Jawa twigs on can make you
hallucinate I guess or he's calling a
dead out of the ground you don't know
yeah ants come up and grab me out of the
ground
yeah there's like there's a spear with
spikes in it that comes out reads and he
could go into your dreams and all this
other kind of stuff and then you know
and then there's there's in the mortuary
there's all these little barrels with
like looks like little shrunken bodies
in it and there's like a portal to
another dimension and each of these
things is just kind of like introduced
yeah it's very easy like I said it's
very unique you know it's not a zombie
movie yeah no it's not vampires no it's
not wearables it's not aliens you know
it's just its own thing you know which
they're kind of creating their own genre
and yeah they're all mythos and I
thought I think
one of the reasons that it's so it was
kind of Lovecraft yet and it was like
some low craft maybe would have dreamt
up I did notice that in one scene the
kid goes to a psychic and he has to put
his hand in a pain box for the witch
and the witches daughter I'm going boy
he's ripping off dude yeah cuz that's
the same thing Paul tradies had to do
you know and he took his hand out there
was nothing wrong with it that's in this
movie and then it cuts to a bar scene
and the name of the bar is what dude
dunes dunes Cantina whose bar here
whatever is well I got this dude's what
this dude likes Frank Herbert yeah
because that scene was very similar to
that for the dune movie yeah he could
have only read the book yeah so yeah he
must have liked that idea yeah but like
I said I mean that was like that's what
gave him his street cred to go up
against tall man that he had passed that
test that was the yeah because that was
the whole I mean the point of that seems
basically saying fear is the mind killer
right and that's how he's getting
through it yeah that was pretty much
what the point of that theme we gotta do
and that's why later on you know he kind
of flashed back to that yes but you know
like I said one of the coolest things
about this movie and and I'm sure I've
mentioned us this on some other reviews
particularly probably my one of them on
Suspiria I really like surrealism in
horror when it's done right I mean you
can do it and it's just stupid and
pretentious or whatever but surrealism
and horror to me if it's done correctly
makes the movie creepier because you
can't get a handle on it it's like a
nightmare like this is why and this
might seem contradictory but I'm never
scared by movies horror movies that have
a premise that could really happen like
a serial killer movie for example I
never I like them but I don't find them
scary even though a serial killer is a
real thing
yeah I'm if I'm gonna be scared by a
movie it's always gonna be something
weird or unexplained because a serial
killer is scary but you know what that
is it's a psycho it's a crazy person
right and it would behave like a crazy
person behaves he can't do supernatural
[ __ ] he can't turn up in your [ __ ]
nightmares he can't do anything like
that when you do surrealism in a horror
movie you don't know what to expect
really
I wonder it taught this tall man
character inspired Freddy Krueger it
could see going into that boys dreams
yeah true that's wonder it's gonna be
inspiration for that it might have been
there was a lot of cool [ __ ] in this
movie yeah another thing that even
though it's like a it's a cheap little
budget flick it's just kind of done well
by guys that cared about it and it's got
one of the baddest-ass hot rods I've
ever seen on there it's kind of like a
71 or 72 Plymouth Barracuda yeah dressed
up to be like a Hemi Cuda yeah and in
the soundtrack when this car goes by man
you hear those high compression pisses
yeah yeah I can't tell you how excited
tom was about that car to stop the movie
and look up and look it up online what
car that one's well from the back end
I'm going is that uh Nova with with a
body kit on it what is that day yeah no
no and oh it's a it's a barracuda
dressed up like a Hemi Cuda well the
whole reasons I thought came included
but it looked cool the whole reason that
that's in the movie is because don
coscarelli evidently had gone to a ghana
high school with a guy that had a car
like that and he really liked it series
I want to put that [ __ ] yeah it's got
the big fat tires it's like an ultimate
70s car that's the car that you you know
you drive around town looking like Han
Solo yeah grab a tittie with it pointed
seventies - yeah that car was badass
it made you want to drink I could do I
could go over some wild turkey write
about a wild turkey yeah the main guy
that's in this that lays the old bottles
yes he looks like if han Solo
what did I say if han Solo and he was
the other guy the Hoff and David
Hasselhoff had a baby if that was
possible so now that's what he looks and
that's what he would look like yeah and
actually I was saying that and it's all
man to me he kind of looked a little bit
like Marlon Brando like at all Marlon
Brando there's some about his face yeah
you said he looked like somebody else I
know and now I can't remember her so
well that do tomorrow that Brando had a
baby then they would be here yeah now I
can't remember
well it's funny because I hadn't seen
the first phantasm in so long and I had
forgotten how much younger angus scrimm
was in this movie because the second one
didn't come out for like another nine
years and who had considerably older
although he didn't angus scrimm did not
die until 2016 I'd say he was
scary-looking dude
yeah they did something in this cheap
low-budget flick that impressed me that
kid looked at a tall black & white photo
of the house and in it is a dude driving
a horse and buggy it's actually like an
old horse-drawn hearse yeah remember
that yep and it was live motion yeah
damn expect that yeah that was actually
that was probably probably one of the
best effects in the yeah I thought and
it was like super creepy that stuff like
that creeps me that net flying ball that
will flying metal ball they never
explained it and that's one of the
strengths of this movie like [ __ ] you
it's good yeah yeah there's leather and
it flies through the air and then blades
show you this [ __ ] and we're not even
explain it
yeah well like I said he did that on
purpose because he really liked movies
where they're just like here's a weird
thing there's a Mazal deal with it cuz
I'm possibly and with this steel ball
flying around in any moment it can just
come and kill you kind of like that
little smiley face that angry face from
that game video game berserk remember
that yeah yeah and oh and I should know
- and I don't want to forget to mention
this and I think I mentioned this in our
burnt-offerings review yeah the house
that's the Morningside Mortuary in
phantasm is the same house that was in
burnt offerings that's right and it was
it was the same as in California
somewhere here in black running around
that's right sexy cross ass yeah
now on I like Kara black eye everybody
loves Karen blighted some about Karen
black nothing magnetic back here she's
so awesome yeah and she's been in so
many cool like horrible yeah I love her
so much
yeah she was kinda struck me as being
slightly cross-eyed she is a little bit
as you look across I didn't know if it
was me my imagination okay excuse a
little bit cause I'm because it could
never really catch it yeah she has
stealth it was sexy though yeah yeah
that's what I mean there is something
like really sexy about her yeah I don't
know it was a same kind of thing with
you know like we were talking about
Adrienne Barbeau yeah good stuff like
that there was just some kind of you
know how to tell yes seventies thing for
some reason there was something about
those people back there battle spits
speaking of the 70s we were kind of
making a lot of jokes about this we were
watching phantasm last night yeah so the
main kid that's in it oh yes now the kid
no I I should be said and I mean this in
the most affectionate possible way and
acting in this nut great I mean these
are obviously he didn't have to be great
though
yeah these are obviously amateur actors
these were Doncaster Ali's friends but
so the kid that was in it you know not a
fantastic actor but I love the kid in
this he's supposed to be 13 right yeah
even that he looks slightly older but
not these four like 17 yeah but he's
supposed to be 13 and I kind of love
because this is made in 1979 no one bats
an eye about the kid one running around
by himself yeah two drinking a whole
six-pack three driving a car watching
his brother knocking down girls yeah
it's just way it was back then you know
I've mentioned it on other all know the
shows that I'm doing back in the 70s you
could just throw 13 all the keys go
there they get some beer kid yeah well
the end that's that's kind of why we
laughed because right the older brother
he's like busy humping this woman in a
cemetery and the brother has been
following him around so he kind of just
gives him the cut gave him the keys to
his Barracuda and he's like hey go home
and they were like yeah go get me some
beer and some yeah
yeah awesome poem on the way go get some
hookers yeah but yeah it's like it's
funny because I thought later on there's
a scene where the Jodi the brother is
sitting on the porch with the
thirteen-year-old kid and he's like
laughing cuz he's like hey five down one
to go with the beers I thought that
might have those things I think that was
a deleted scene though yeah I don't know
I think that was no watch we watched all
the deleted scenes on the blu-ray which
they're worth watching and in the
deleted scenes it's a but to say this
bunch of [ __ ] that kid was doing that
they had to cut out alcohol they were
getting drunk I don't think they were
smoking weed but no I don't remember any
weed smoking yeah but the thing well the
funniest thing about it and you can kind
of tell this because like I said this
movie was filmed like on weekends like
over a year it only cost about 300,000
dollars to make roughly Don Coscarelli
said I don't really know because we made
it over a long period of time ended up
making almost 12 million so that's a
pretty good pretty successful run
basically he's like well I had to edit
out a lot of cuz a lot of the stuff was
improvised which you will see if you
watch the movie I mean some of it does
look every no though I think I think
that gives it a better feel though yeah
it seems like a home movie is very
organic yeah and even even though you
definitely tell that the acting's not
that good and some of the sets are fake
there's this there's an amount of
honesty in this movie well in there yeah
there's like it's kind of like a lot of
movies from that period even if they
were to Polly made before I could yeah
well there's some kind of like
atmosphere as been a vibe about them
that's really enjoyable
and this has that too it's funny because
Don Coscarelli was like okay well I made
the movie with all the scenes still in
it and he showed it he paid some people
to come at watch it like before he
released it and he called that screening
a disaster yeah and he said that people
responded well to like the nightmarish
surreal as aparts but he's like there
was too much quote-unquote character
development which I guess where's all
those scenes like where Reggie and Jodie
are sitting on the porch playing guitar
there was one scene that was actually
cut out that was like a big essentially
a food fight yeah in Reggie's ice-cream
parlor
we're like the kid like passed out drunk
and they all
I scream on him and then they were like
eating again eating it off between his
legs or two cookies buns like a dick and
balls ice cream this supposedly 13y it's
a hilarious movie in a certain way
minute it's it is what it is okay I do
recommend the blu-ray the restorations
really good the soundtracks good the
music's good for what it is yeah it's
that type of [ __ ] movie yeah you know
it's like it's like the movies of the
era yeah but I think punching above its
weight it's doing a lot with very little
and like I said the best thing about
this is the concept the mythos that it
introduces which kind of got explored a
lot in the later it receives me us in
many ways of the Evil Dead the very
first it is very yeah it is very much
like not a zany no not a zany and not
quite as as special effects intensive
right has that same kind of a vibe I
wouldn't surprise me if Evil Dead was
slightly inspired by this movie in a
certain way but I think the evil that
had a bigger budget yeah but probably
not by much but it definitely had the
same these are a group of friends who
really into horror they had this crazy
idea and we're just gonna like film it
over the course of a few weekends or
something and we're all gonna just kind
of hang out and do whatever we want to
see the other ones now well yeah like I
said and I'm gonna say no I haven't seen
phantasm too in a while like I said I
saw in the theater when it came out in
1988 and I probably saw on a cable again
once more many years later but I haven't
seen it for many years I remember liking
the second one more than the first one
well then I'm looking forward to some
yeah I think it was a little more
cohesive I don't remember it explaining
that much more but I think that was kind
of a strength of it like I said I kind
of liked that they were just like here's
this mortuary with this guy in it all
this weird [ __ ] happens and you just
have to deal with it they don't explain
it or what happens or anything like that
we'll definitely have to do at least
part two because yeah because I remember
liking that okay yeah I'm a fan now now
I wants to gather with ya and there were
you know obviously there was another one
phantasm three was Lord of the Dead that
came out in 1994 I don't
no if I saw that one or not I might have
I don't know if this restored version is
on YouTube for rent maybe it is maybe it
is yeah I have to check for yourself but
the restored version is it looks really
good yeah and I didn't it didn't cost
you much I think I got it for about nine
dollars delivered ten dollars delivery
yeah and it looks great I mean it looks
like oh my god it proudly in my
collection but yeah the funny thing too
is that there was a phantasm for called
oblivion that came out in 1998 and I
didn't realize this but one came out in
2016
phantasm Ravager we're gonna watch I'm
watching one at a time I was like I
don't even remember who was an Tet was
angus scrimm even in that i mean he died
that year but i don't know if that if he
would have been interact because it's
not really it can't be phantasm without
angus scrimm and yeah and he's too cause
he's so freaky looking like i said
before i'm not - i'm not too dependent
on characters in the movies like you
know Halloween 3 doesn't have Michael
Myers in it but that's one of my
favorite even think I don't consider it
to be a Halloween yeah I don't consider
it part it's franchise because he said
totally crazy so animals a standalone
yes it's crazy you know crazy good
low-budget horror flick I was gonna
mention something about Angus Scrimm who
played the tall man they said in the in
the first movie he was actually wearing
lifts and issues so he would look taller
dog and they also he got him a suit
I also got him a suit that was too small
so he would look bigger
no he'd look thinner and taller like
more look more scarecrow like yeah he
was weird-looking he's a weird-looking
dude and remembered him in the I
remember him from the trailer as a kid
seeing him I remember seeing that guy
gone whoo yeah well don coscarelli he
had worked with angus scrimm on another
movie earlier and he was so freaked out
by that guy but that's why he wanted him
to be the baddie in his movie because he
was so strange looking yeah I mean he
couldn't really play any I've seen him
in other movies since then but he's
scarier and lurched me yeah he can't
will lurch was kind of lovable like I
always had a crush on when I was a cutie
original lurch tenacity when I saw that
as a kid though you know large yeah he
looks scary until I knew the character
yeah when you first see him
he was such a nice man now yeah do you
know he's um he's from I think he's from
Florida actually he might even front be
from Daytona Beach or from the area that
I'm from oka he's to be a lifeguard
isn't that funny huh you don't really
you know imagine lurch being a lifeguard
Frankenstein's monster yeah
but anyway okay so any horror fans I'm
sure you've probably seen the original
Phantom if you haven't you should
definitely watch it like I said it's
very low-budget obviously yes it's kind
of amateurish but in a way that the
first Evil Dead is amateur should hit
that same but not as wacky if you like
people dead one you'll like this yeah
and like I said the concept behind it is
just so cool and if you really like
surrealist horror like I do then you
really need to see it if you would
definitely hit you with phantasm -
because I'm gonna order that I want to
see that one yeah and I haven't seen it
in ages and I remember really liking it
a lot okay
okay so that'll do it for our latest
movie review remember if you liked our
show to Like share subscribe on all your
social media and if you'd like to
contribute to the show you can go to our
patreon at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or if you'd like to give a
one-time donation through PayPal you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress comm and there's a
link in the sidebar to a PayPal account
also be sure to check out our regular
episodes which come out every Tuesday
and our movie reviews which come out
every Friday and until next time bye